I started to drink a little bit in my at
the age of 42. very nice yeah because
you were not known in alcohol coffee and
alcohol I love this this is a new bold
new chapter we're gonna have some fun
let loose a little bit you know Kim
Kardashian opens up about why she
decided to start drinking alcohol in her
40s the biggest misconception of me is
that I'm a wild crazy party girl I mean
I don't even drink alcohol so I can't
stay up too late and party yeah Kim's
made it pretty clear in the past she was
never a fan of boozy beverages but now
that she's made a change the mama for a
dish why on the goop podcast with
Gwyneth Paltrow why are you allowing
yourself to let loose now cause why not
you know I just feel like
I work a lot and I focus really like all
day after school then it's like product
meetings and testing things and
packaging meetings and everything for
skin
Kim says between mom life work life and
studying for the bar she barely has any
time to let her hair down but when she
allows herself to take a breather a
drink helps I just don't ever feel
comfortable just like laying around
doing nothing
so right my version of that has been to
spend some time with my friends and have
a drink and stay out a little bit later
when I probably wouldn't have done that
before even if I'm a little bit tired
the next day in my workout just that
time it's really lit and fun and crazy
Kim makes it clear she's not drinking on
The Daily and she isn't one for wine but
when she does indulge she goes for just
tequila
yeah just has to be like a little shot
of pineapple and a shot of tequila
perfect yeah that's so beautiful two
shots and I'm like so good
it's been fun there's different sides of
me so while this is the first time we're
hearing him explain her Newfound
appreciation for liquor we've seen
little glimpses here and there on social
media like back in August during her sis
Kylie Jenner's birthday celebration Kim
totally went for it even if it didn't go
down smoothly
[Music]
yeah guessing at the time she was still
getting used to the taste
so while Kim's having fun in cocktails
with her friends she also reveals to
Gwyneth that she's still open to the
idea of getting hitched again why not I
have this like fantasy in my head like
fourth time's a charm it's gonna work
out now I feel like I will definitely
take my time and I would be okay for
like a forever partnership as well I
think I would definitely want I would
want a marriage but
I'm so happy to take my time a somewhat
surprising Revelation that comes just a
month after Kim finalized her divorce
from her third husband Kanye West I
definitely protected him and I still
will in
the eyes of my kids for my kids prior to
yay the skims founder was married to
Damon Thomas and Chris Humphries
for now the beauty Mogul says she wants
to be single for a few years so Kim we
support you and say cheers two shots and
I'm like so good
it's been fun
[Music]